what's going on guys this is rob and
rumors are abound that more lun is going
to appear in spider-man no way home i
don't know if that's true i hope it's
true in case it is true we're going to
do a video explaining more lunch so this
could be one of those videos where it
just bombs in its entirety which is fine
or it just does exceedingly well because
sony's like more lines in the movie and
then everybody's looking it up right
everybody's looking up this guy right so
here's the thing morelan is part of a
group called the inheritors and the role
they play is to basically travel around
the multiverse and kill spider totems
specifically but really animal totems
anywhere they can find them so here's
the thing to grasp and and this is kind
of an important talking point here to
really grasp what's going on with what
we're going to be discussing we need to
kind of run over the nature of marvel
reworking the amazing spider-man comics
back in the late 1990s not a super long
explanation here but it is important so
as most of you guys know spider-man
appeared in amazing fantasy issue number
15. eventually marvel gave him his own
solo series in the amazing spider-man
that ran for 441 issues until 1998 in
1999 marvel reworked it and relaunched
it as amazing spider-man vol 2 that ran
for 58 issues at the end of that issue
they brought back amazing spider-man vol
1 and continued the numbering as 500
going forward what this means is that if
you wanted to read amazing spider-man
from start to finish which is a colossal
undertaking but if you wanted to do that
you would quite literally read the
amazing spider-man vol 1 all the way up
to issue 441 then you would read amazing
spider-man vol 2 issue 1 to number 58
and then you would continue on with
amazing spider-man vol 1 issue number
500. now the reason why i bring that up
is because the idea of amazing
spider-man vol 2 and the reason why more
line is important here is because this
was part of a larger story arc that was
being told primarily by j michael
cerzinski but also involving writers
like reginald hudland and peter david
that basically focus on a concept called
the other now the funny thing about this
is the other was actually part of a
bigger thing that was referred to as
spider totems and this is one of those
concepts that j michael strzenski by way
of marvel created and depending on who
you talk to some people may say they
love it some may say they hate it the
important thing here is that for years
and years and years and years peter
parker was just a kid who was bitten by
a radioactive spider and became a hero
done pretty straightforward during
strazinsky's run what you got was this
introduction of a guy named ezekiel sims
and ezekiel sims was a person who had
essentially attained the powers of
spider-man and then was being hunted by
more lunt and so what he started doing
was assembling all this information that
he could to understand the nature of
morlun as a person and what he
represents now this is when we get into
the history portion now this history
portion isn't really revealed until you
get to the actual spider-verse event
until you get to superior spider-man of
course the story that focused on dr
octopus taking over the body of peter
parker but what you learn is that
somewhere along the line and we're not
really given a definitive date it's just
like a long time ago it's really all you
get that morlun and his family also
called the inheritors existed in a
universe called earth one and what you
have here is something called the master
weaver and the web of life and destiny
now the web of life and destiny is
basically just a gateway to the
multiverse right for spiders it's really
all it is if you guys are familiar with
the flash think of it as like the
spider-man equivalent to like the speed
force right except you can basically
travel through into different universes
instead of just being stuck in it
seemingly for all of eternity so that's
kind of how that works but there always
has to be a master weaver which is to
say a person that is basically
controlling the web of life and destiny
to ensure the multiverse stays balanced
now a lot of people do this and for
those of you guys who are inevitably
going to ask this question no marvel
never consolidates the difference
between like the master weaver and
whether or not he knows about or
associates with the imcron crystal how
his power relates to somebody who can
travel the multiverse or anything along
those lines it's just a concept dealing
with the multiverse that exists out
there right so just take it with a grain
of salt and roll with it but what we
find out is that somewhere along the
line morlun and his family realized that
they would basically gain power and keep
their existence going by killing spider
totems and so when they initially
stormed the home of the master weaver at
the time what you had as part of the
inheritors as part of that family was a
guy named karn now karn didn't like
killing spider totems he didn't like any
of that stuff and we'll explain spider
totems here in a second but he didn't
like the vicious nature of the inheritor
family however because of the fact that
he was a part of that family and
essentially standing against them would
constitute death what he ended up doing
was basically hiding that he just kind
of went along with the hunt and did what
he was supposed to do and that was
basically it but when the house of the
master weaver was stormed and the father
of the inheritors basically solace
showed up that one the master weaver was
essentially taken over and then replaced
by karn once the master weaver revealed
to the family that karn didn't like
killing anything and so that's why when
you go into the events of spider-verse
or any of that stuff karn is basically
the master weaver the one that controls
the web of life and destiny but the
important thing here is that spider
totems were a relatively new thing what
this meant is that when peter parker was
bitten by a radioactive spider he
basically became a spider avatar in the
sense that like black panther is an
avatar for the panther god bast peter
parker is an avatar for the web of life
and destiny right the master weaver the
spider totem concept so is anybody else
who's ever been bitten by a radioactive
spider that's why the events of
spider-verse were literally all these
spider-man from across the multiverse
fighting the inheritors but the
important thing here is that with
ezekiel sims basically gaining all this
information what he sought to do was one
protect himself from the inheritors and
two protect anybody out there who would
become a future host for
basically the spider totems to keep them
safe from the inheritors the bigger
problem that you have here is that the
inheritors don't really seem to be able
to be defeated by conventional means and
even ezekiel sims believed the
inheritors were virtually indestructible
so the best you could do was create some
kind of a stop gap measure to basically
hide right to just sit in a bunker
somewhere and hide and that would
basically be it and those are a lot of
the preparations that he made now as for
morlan himself following peter's
encounter with ezekiel and ezekiel
actually sacrificing his life to save
peter morlun started hunting peter
parker and the crazy thing about this is
that as this hunt began to take place
peter was painfully unprepared because
morlun had done this countless times
they initially started on earth one they
basically killed all the spider totems
there or at least most of them and then
following that they used the web of life
and destiny to start killing spider
totems throughout the multiverse so they
had been hunting spider-man and spider
women for quite some time and so in a
lot of ways it was really a cat and
mouse game it was more lon just kind of
stalking peter messing with peter you
know attacking him here and there
causing a few problems and in fact this
had gone on for quite some time between
issues number 30 and issue number 35
that morlun was constantly hunting and
stalking peter now there did come a
point when the two of them made physical
contact and the significance of that was
that up to that point peter could run
virtually anywhere and it'd be very very
difficult for moreland to find him but
as soon as the two of them had touched
more lun would immediately be able to
know where he is no matter where he was
right so peter parker could like
teleport to the other side of the world
or be in antarctica somewhere and more
lund would eventually be able to find
him hence the nature of the bunkers that
ezekiel had formed which were designed
to keep people safe and keep them hidden
away so long as peter was in one of
those bunkers more lun would never be
able to get to him and so over the
course of these ensuing conflicts there
were some huge revelations that were
basically given to us the first is that
morlun is incredibly strong so much so
that in amazing spider-man vol 2 issue
number 32 peter actually makes the
comment that he'd never been hit that
hard by anybody even the incredible hulk
had never hit him that hard right morlun
was just seemingly on a whole separate
level the second thing about this was
that peter had gotten his hands on a
sample of moreland's blood and had
actually gone through and analyzed it
and realized that while marlon is
hunting spider totems the reality is
that he's actually hunted everything
right that he feeds on the life force of
these individuals who represent these
animals within the the totem system
itself and so because his blood is
contained panther dna and all this kind
of stuff the indication here is that in
alternate realities he had killed black
panthers he had killed these various
individuals that basically represented
animals in their superhero form and so
all this came to a head in amazing
spider-man vol 2 issue number 35 when
peter had basically realized that while
morlun feeds on the life force of
fighter totems or really any totem then
he has to essentially feed on them in
the same way that a vampire does which
seemingly means consuming their blood or
at least the energy that makes up that
person and so peter actually ended up
injecting himself with radiation with
nuclear radiation and then when moreland
went to go feed on him he ultimately
ended up realizing that peter was just
totally imbued with all this radioactive
energy at the same time he was basically
shot and killed by his henchmen but
basically he crumbled the dust the idea
behind this and the reason why this is
important is because seemingly the way
strazinsky wrote this story it was
self-contained it was five issues long
moreland was just a guy who was there
and you were never going to see or hear
from him again that it seemed to be part
of the bigger landscape which was
building on the concept of spider totems
that peter was just one aspect of what
it meant to be a spider deity that there
were other versions out there things
like the other and so on and so forth
and that's where the other storyline
really began to pick up you had friendly
neighborhood spider-man you had marvel
knight spider-man and you had the
amazing spider-man which again by this
point had basically been renumbered to
500 so that portion of the story takes
place in amazing spider-man vol 1 issue
number 525 but over the course of these
stories right so friendly neighborhood
spider-man 1 2 and 3 marvel knight
spider-man 19 20 21 and amazing
spider-man vol 1 525 526 and 527 over
the course of these different acts a
handful of things happened one of them
is that more lun had seemingly returned
and we weren't really given an
indication as to why he was just there
and it was one of those interesting
things because it was just kind of a way
for marvel to at least bring back what
fans consider to be a very interesting
and compelling villain and looking at
the letters pages as far as i can guess
there wasn't really a whole lot of
concern as to how he got back fans were
just kind of interested to see what
would happen now that he was there the
other part of this is that peter parker
seemed to be dying now the idea of peter
parker dying was really marvel just kind
of hand waving it and saying well peter
parker quote unquote dying can't be
explained by science but there's
something mystical going on behind the
scenes it ties back to the beginning of
strazinsky's run and the idea of the
spider totem so again kind of building
up that mystery and that intrigue the
important thing here is that by the time
you'd finished the other storyline peter
parker had faced off against morlun yet
again only this time morlun had almost
beat peter parker to death and in fact
he was going to kill him on the spot the
cops showed up so we ended up leaving
and then returning to the hospital where
peter parker was being held and where a
kind of attack took place whereby mirror
jane watson showed up she tried to save
peter morlund beat the crap out of her
peter parker popped out of nowhere and
it was kind of crazy when it happened
right because like he was missing an eye
so literally he he just like sits up out
of bed looking like a mummy right his
head's all wrapped up like the one eye
he does have is like red and bulging
he's got like these super sharp teeth
like he literally attacks more lawn and
rips his throat out and then more lung
just basically dies right he crumbles to
dust and so that was the end of that now
there was an instance uh where more lun
was brought back during reginald
hudlin's run on black panther it was
pretty cool of course this story took
place after the events of doom war so
basically t'challa had lost the title of
black panther he had given it to his
sister shuri due to an injury he'd
sustained and when the events of doom
war were over that t'challa refused to
take the mantle back it was now his
sister's right and with jonathan hickman
basically riding the fantastic four at
the time part of the conclusion dealt
with t'challa getting with reed richards
traveling to meet the panther goddess
fast and then basically receiving the
new title as the king of the dead and so
following that uh morlan had actually
basically reappeared during the events
of the great hunt now as far as what was
going on with peter parker at the time
that focused on the whole idea of the
other so peter parker embracing what it
meant to be an actual spider-man and
then basically becoming a giant spider
at the end of the day this basically
segued into the events of one more day
and that was the end of it right it was
basically uh joe gasada coming along and
saying okay like this this needs to end
right this is done we're gonna reset
peter parker everything's gonna go back
to normal and essentially wrapping it
all up ending the marriage between peter
parker and mary jane watson sending
peter parker back to the version that we
know where it's just peter parker a kid
who was bitten by a radioactive spider
and that was that essentially resetting
the mythos back to zero and so following
that you went into dan slot's run now
the idea here and this is kind of an
important thing if we ignore the
resurrection of morlun during reginald
hudlin's black panther run and we focus
exclusively on the events of the other
as the last time that we actually saw
more lun it was years before he came
back there were a series of events
during original sin the story that
basically dealt with all these secrets
these things the watcher had seen that
nobody knew existed but morlan had
actually returned again we weren't
really given a definitive explanation as
to how that happened we simply just knew
that it did but over the course of dan
slot's run starting with big time of
course we covered all that that was
reworking spider-man right that was the
kind of bringing spider-man back from
from what was basically zero kind of
like this big really hard reset for the
character and just running forward from
there and that basically led into what
we call spider-verse now spider-verse
was an amazing story right spider-verse
was a phenomenal story this basically
took place again during the events of
superior spider-man so by this point in
time peter parker was by and large this
kind of a distant memory within his own
psyche and that dr octopus was basically
the one running the show but the thing
about this is that you ended up learning
that yes more lon was back and they were
going on this crusade to kill all these
different spider totems from across the
multiverse but what made spider-verse so
cool is that it was essentially dr
octopus being the one who began to
initiate this sort of coming together
that he had gone through these different
realities and discovered all these
different spider-man that had been
killed in these different alternate
universes that seemingly the spider-man
from the house of m universe was
destroyed spider-man from other
universes in spite of women from other
universes were killed and so basically
he organized this kind of unified front
however something that i do want to
point out here is that when it comes to
the spider-verse event it was less about
more lund specifically and more about
the inheritors as a whole trying to
essentially cast a ritual that would
wipe out all the spider totems from
across the multiverse and allow the
inheritors to consume their essence
right making them even more powerful
than before and so in a lot of ways it
was just kind of a multi-faceted
conflict so saying that spider-verse is
a story that focuses on more lon it's
like saying that marvel's civil war
focuses exclusively on captain america
there's a lot of focus on him in that
story but he's only one part of the
story and somewhere line you actually
ended up learning over the course of
that unlike the other inheritors that
hunted really more out of necessity or
anything like that that morlun harbored
a personal vengeance for peter parker
spider-man the other part of this is
that he was actually terrified of the
main marvel universe because he'd been
killed three times there and a lot of
this had been due to the history morlun
had which was traveling through the
multiverse and then just kind of running
around killing various superheroes in
his efforts to track down that
universe's spider-man and then
successfully killing him and really
doing it unopposed so earth 616 the main
marvel universe was really the first
time where lon had experienced a spider
totem that not only was able to go toe
to toe with him but it actually killed
him three times and so it was one of
those things that sort of freaked him
out and so again because this was part
of a much larger story which if you guys
are interested i guess we could remaster
it uh i don't know that's not something
that i would do with my own accord i
would only really do it if you guys
actually wanted me to but at the
conclusion of that story and because the
inheritors were especially weak to what
was basically nuclear radiation they
were basically left stranded in a
universe called earth 3145 now this was
a universe where uncle ben had actually
become spider-man instead of peter or
aunt may and in fact peter and aunt may
had been killed and so when ezekiel sims
in that universe had actually asked him
if he wanted to hide out in one of the
bunkers just because of the fact that
the inheritors were hunting them that
ben parker ended up hiding out there but
during that point in time or while he
was in that bunker a giant global
nuclear war had broken out due to the
actions of dr octopus and basically the
entire world was irradiated and devoid
of life the only exception being uncle
ben and so when of course he was
discovered by silk basically cindy moon
another spider totem but because of the
fact that she had discovered ben he was
of course brought on to the forces of
the spider-man unified front if you want
to call it that and so the inheritors
were basically stranded in that world
there was really no way for them to
escape because karen had already been
killed so the web of life and destiny
had largely been destroyed there was no
way for them to navigate outside of that
universe and so by all saying there's a
measurement the way dan slott had wrote
this they were locked away forever it
was basically done right it was it there
was really no indication that moreland
or any of his guys were ever going to
come back now as you guys can imagine
because of the popularity of
spider-verse right in case you're not
familiar spider-verse was a colossal
story it was overwhelmingly popular i
mean people absolutely loved it or they
absolutely hated it but regardless
everybody was talking about it right it
was just one of those comic book stories
because it was so massive in scope and
because it was so popular this of course
led marvel to launching an event called
spider-geddon which was written by
christos gage now christo skage is
normally a fantastic spider-man writer
and it actually been riding alongside
dan's slot for quite some time spider
again for a lot of people including
myself really seemed more like a cash
grab this kind of last ditch effort to
capitalize on what little popularity was
left of the events of spider-verse
especially with the end of the
spider-verse film being released and all
that kind of stuff and so while it was
only about five issues long it just as
far as i'm aware wasn't as well received
as the original spider-verse event and
in fact i thought it was pretty
lackluster which was disappointing
because christo stage was an amazing
writer so maybe it was one of those
editorial decisions that marvel made
regardless that story basically focused
on the idea that the inheritors had
basically escaped the the uh universe
they were confined in from earth 3145
and basically ended up putting their
essences in clone bodies and basically
teleporting their spirits to the main
marvel universe and then attacking the
spider-man it was okay but it wasn't
that great right i mean if you've never
read it you're not missing anything it's
not a huge deal i guess it is kind of
important for the writing of moreland
just because of the fact that when you
got to amazing spider-man vol 5 written
by matthew rosenberg and nick spencer
that what you ended up getting was
basically more lund returning now morlan
initially showing up was basically
dealing with the the character of sin
eater of course sin eater was a guy
named stanley carter who'd been around
since 1985 so he wasn't really a new
character but the idea behind sin eater
is that he could quote unquote cleanse
you so he could basically strip you of
your sins but he would usually turn them
into like spirit monsters that would
torment you and he essentially got the
upper hand on mourinho and actually
destroyed him now eventually moreland
did return to his traditional form which
actually happened in what was basically
an attempt by nick spencer and matthew
rosenberg to correct one of the most
questionable decisions marvel comics had
ever made okay let's check this out
sidetrack here there was this point in
marvel comics where they had this genius
idea to introduce this concept that
norman osborne the green goblin and gwen
stacy were having an affair
terrible decision it was terror it was a
terrible editorial decision by marvel
like literally no one liked it no one
wanted it it's considered one of the
most reviled and embarrassing moments in
the history of marvel comics so matthew
rosenberg and nick spencer tried to fix
that by creating what were called the
kindred twins and essentially this was
just kind of wrapping around to the
events of that original story where they
said what had actually happened is
norman osborne had used mendel strom who
was at one point his business partner in
the early days of him stepping into the
role of becoming the green goblin to
basically take the dna of norman osborne
and the dna of gwen stacy create twins
and then just be like yeah man me and
gwen stacy were banging haha peter
gotcha man it wasn't enough that i uh
that i killed gwen stacy i also banged
her too and she had kids you know it's
just like damn man like the dude the new
bang's your girl and then kills her like
man that's messed up right it was it was
a pretty wild thing but this was an
effort to basically correct all that i'm
neither one way or the other but the
important thing here is that when when
stanley carter had learned he'd been
manipulated by the kindred twins he
actually killed himself and when that
happened the essence the energy he'd
absorbed from more lon actually went
back to moreland himself and that
basically led to moreland returning in
his traditional form now what that means
for the future of morlan and marvel
comics i'm not entirely sure technically
i'm not caught up on sinister war so i'm
not entirely sure how that story ended i
know i'm slacking i'm sorry guys there's
just too many comics for me to keep up
with man it's tough to do but the
important thing here is that it's likely
more lund will return at some future
point in time especially if it's true
that he's going to be in spider-man no
way home but again this is all just kind
of rumor moreland's kind of a tough
character to explain guys i'm not going
to lie it's one of these things where
he's really more important because of
the circumstances surrounding him as
opposed to moreland himself right i mean
you could replace more alone with almost
anybody and it would have had just the
same weight and gravity so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end thank you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace